Так, будь ласка, можемо заходити!
Сент-Міклош названий так,
тому що це давня назва цього селища.
Перша згадка про нього була в 1214 році,
коли цьому селищу була дана грамота,
і в цій грамоті селище значиться як «Sante Nicolao»
на латині, тобто святий Миколай.
Спочатку це була одноповерхова кам'яна будівля,
котру купив князь Імре Текелі за 22 тисячі форинтів.
Сьогодні в Угорщині
це вартість хорошої пляшки Токайського вина.
Цієї цінності ... словом, заклад був куплений і
добудований приблизно в такому вигляді,
в якому зараз ви його побачите.
Цим замком володіло дуже багато княжих родів.
В 2001 році нам вдалося взяти
його в оренду, щоб відновити,
і на його базі створити міжнародний
культурно-мистецький та туристичний центр.
Наш парк — це окрема історія.
Одна із найбільш неймовірних історій,
яка може бути.
Тут кожна зупинка має своє значення.
Кожний камінець у цьому парку має теж своє значення.
Якщо сюди приходить геолог,
котрий розуміється на каміннях,
він вам на цьому камені
прочитає всю історію створення Землі.
Ви бачите тут закам'янілі рослини,
лаву розпечену, котра застигала періодично,
і так відбувалася побудова землі.
Будь-який геолог, котрий знається на цьому,
вам одразу по цьому камінню розповідає про всі періоди,
які тут відбувалися мільйони років тому назад.
Нам дуже цікаво, що саме така карта побудови
Землі виявилася нашою доріжкою,
котра має певну форму, як це було при замках.
Парк був заснований у 1749 році.
На запрошення графа Фон Шенборн сюди приїхав
відомий парковий майстер Франц Бошинда.
І тут, на цьому місці площею близько десяти гектарів
розбив чудовий англійський парк.
Цей парк був «удачно» знищений
радянськими військами у 1947 році.
Взагалі, нічого не залишилося, ні одного деревця.
Після цього у 1985 році армія відійшла і це стала автобаза.
Сталося так, що автобаза збанкрутувала,
і нам вдалося викупити цю територію.
Зараз ми вже розібрали всі гаражі і майстерні, котрі тут були.
І пробуємо своїми силами відновити цей парк
приблизно по описах, які були в той час.
На цій площі ви бачите залишки тієї території.
Єдиний гараж, який ми не розібрали...
Хотіли вже розбирати, але потім виявилося,
що його форма і пропорції абсолютно
нагадують базиліку IV століття.
І це був нонсенс: як військовий інженер
міг збудувати базиліку IV століття?
Немає тільки перехресного хреста.
І алтаря...
Тому ми вирішили його не розбирати,
а зробити в ньому храм Аполлона.
Тобто, великий органний концертний зал,
написати великі батальні картини,
зробити великі скульптури,
котрі показували б героїчний шлях замку,
і героїчний шлях цієї землі.
Першочергова задача тут, в цьому приміщенні —
це розібрати ті вкраплення,
котрі робила радянська армія.
Ті, котрі залишилися ще з тих часів.
Наприклад, цеглини, котрі були вставлені тут,
щоб ліси укріпляти.
І з того часу, так як вони непотрібні були,
вони залишали їх.
Зараз ми ці цеглини виймаємо
і на їхнє місце ставимо камінь, котрий був тут спочатку.
І зараз вікна, котрі радянська армія вже
добудувала, ми знищуємо і робимо такі вікна,
які були саме у XVI-XVII столітті.
Ну звичайно, декілька шарів штукатурки,
це було дуже нерозумно —
на вапняну штукатурку класти цемент.
Один матеріал не витримує інший, вони несумісні.
Вона відпадає сама,
нам навіть не треба її збивати.
Ну!...
Заходьте, заходьте...
Всі заходьте...
По одному...
Заходьте, заходьте, заходьте...
Тут займаються підготовкою студентів для вступу...
Фактично тут проходять усі уроки.
У нас окремо є музичний клас і клас для вивчення мов.
У нас викладається угорська та німецька мови.
Сподіваємося і англійську отримаємо,
але поки що з учителями проблема.
Змінилася якість викладання, так як у нас вже є студенти,
котрі вступили у Львівський університет.
Викладачі приймають їх з відкритими руками.
Найголовніше це —
дати зрозуміти дітям, що вчитися потрібно.
І не все так просто у цьому житті.
Це наші конюшні.
Ще 3 роки тому вони були гаражами...
Зараз ми ліквідували всі ці гаражі,
і на тому місці, де був великий гараж,
ми відновлюємо конюшні,
котрі були збудовані ще в XVI столітті.
Саме князем Францем Другим.
Потім сім'я Фон Шенбурн в 1750 році
зробила тут кінний завод, але він тут не мав успіху.
Він працював деякий час як кінний заавод.
Зараз нам вдалося виграти невеличкий грант в Угорщині,
ми купили двох коней торійської породи.
З тих двох коней вже стало три,
і ми їх використовуємо для їзди на нашій кареті,
а також в сідлах, і вони будуть
виступати у лицарських боях.
Нам невідомо, скільки було коней за часів Ракоці,
але думаю, що їх було немало.
Відомо, що за часів...
Я прошу мене не чіпати, коли я даю інтерв'ю...
Шановна пані, прошу вас не чіпати мій піджак.
Це наша Фрея, котра народилася тут, у замку,
буквально через 2 тижні,
як ми купили нашу Нінару і нашу Стихію.
У нас проходить фестиваль історичних
реконструкцій «Срібний Татош»,
куди ми запрошуємо вже чотири роки поспіль
Львівський каретний двір,
де лицарі роблять бої,
а також показові виступи саме на цих конях.
До цього ми і готуємося.
Думаю, наступного року зможемо
виконувати якісь виступи.
Наша Софія працює з ними щодня.
Це торійська порода, вона вважається
універсальною породою, вона упряжно-верхова.
ЇЇ можна використовувати як і для прогулянок верхи,
так і трошки для спорту і для упряжі.
Тобто, якщо в них немає туристичної роботи,
ми їх інколи використовуємо, як тягову силу.
Сіно привезти, людям інколи щось привезти.
Зорати...
Це як хоббі і робота...
Мені так пощастило: поєднувати і хоббі, і роботу.
Фактично, це цілий спосіб життя:
не можна сказати, що замок — це робота.
Якщо ти зв'язався з замком, то це повністю змінює
твоє життя і це не можна назвати роботою.
Замок — це спосіб життя Сент-Міклош.
Можна сміливо сказати,
що цей замок врятували художники.
Тут ще не було ні вікон, ні дверей....
художники малювали картини і залишали нам.
І тут проходили наші відкриття
і закриття міжнародних пленерів...
І на ці закриті виставки ми
запрошували журналістів — мас-медіа,
щоб отримати відпровідь на одне запитання.
Нам потрібна культурна спадщина
або вона нам непотрібна?
Ця експозиція змінюється дуже часто,
до нас приїжджають художники з Одеси, наприклад,
з Харкова, з Києва і навіть були з Німеччини.
Це картина-копія Тетяни Бартош, писанкарки, моєї дружини.
Вона зробилась у копію.
А це вже роботи її студентів,
котрі навчаються в учбових закладах.
Насправді фантазію розвити дуже важко
і вибрати з людини.
Це одна із основних задач,
тому що тут доводиться стикатися
ще й з характером кожної дитини і віковим категоріям.
Тому що, якщо дати повну свободу,
то людина не знає, що з нею робити в такому віці.
Її треба розвивати далі, бо якщо є фантазія
і багатий людський розвиток,
то академізм вона спрйимає набагато краще.
Я в цьому пересвідчилася за багато років своєї роботи.
Якщо під час екскурсії ми говоримо, що температура
в замках була 13-14-15 градусів, то в нас було 11.
Але 10 років ми там прожили.
Це були наші найкращі 10 років.
Потім ми викупили цю автобазу
і зробили тут собі житло.
І зараз живемо там,
але мріємо повернутися в замок.
Прошу, проходьте в нашу оселю.
Оце наша художня майстерня.
Це місце Тетяни, вона тут малює свої картини.
Вона тут готується до уроків, саме тут складає плани.
Це моє робоче місце: картина,
яка вже 6 або 7 років лежить і чекає, коли я її закінчу...
Грандіозна трансформація, про яку ми і не мріяли.
Нам територію виміряли метр від замку і все.
Решта було все під автобазою і тому отримати колись
цю автобазу було просто неможливо.
Але в світі є добрі люди.
Збільшилися і пропозиції замкові, тобто ми можемо
не тільки екскурсію провести для туристів,
а і реконструкцію, де вони візьмуть безпосередньо участь.
Одягти на себе обладунки: м'які або бойові
і спробувати, що таке отримати мечом по грудях.
Середньовічну кухню спробувати,
прослухати презентацію якихось книг.
Всі закарпатські письменники
тут презентують свої книги.
Є в нас багато чого...